Hello, I'm Sean from the Burp Suite desktop development team. Today I'm here to tell you
about a new way to customize Burp and make it do things that you want it to do. You have always
been able to customize Burp using the Montoya or the Wiener API to create an extension. Extensions
are very powerful but they require you to know quite a lot of Java and also how to build Java
systems using either Maven or Gradle. So we have added the ability for you to write a mini extension
at the point you need it directly in Burp. We are calling these mini extensions BAMDAS. If you are
comfortable with JavaScript I think you'll find BAMDAS quite straightforward. Let's switch over
to Burp for a demo. We get a lot of feature requests to enhance the proxy filter as you can see here.
Everything from show me like 202 status codes to I want to see everything with a mismatched content
length. So we thought this would be the perfect place to introduce BAMDAS. So here's our first BAMDAS.
The idea is simple. You write a function that decides what shows up in your history. You return true
an item appears. So I've had apply that shows all the history items and you return false
to not show in history. So this will hide all the history items. How this works is every item is
represented by this variable the request response and we can make decisions on whether to show it or
not. So if we go back to our status code 202 example I'll quickly show you how it's done. So we have a request
response which represents a row in the history item. As you can see there's lots of order complete
to help you out. So we want to see if the response has a status code of 202. And it's as simple as that.
We had apply and this is the only response with the status code 202. Now
most of you are thinking you could have done this using regular expressions. And you're right we could have.
But we can this is really powerful. So I have a BAMDAS that I wrote here earlier that I'll explain.
Let me just minimize that. So here's the BAMDAS that shows you mismatched content length. So what I've done in this BAMDAS
is I've assigned the response to a variable. I'm not interested in any responses that don't have a content
length so I just return false for all of those guys. Then I pause the responses header for the content
length read it into a variable. I get the actual content length of the response and then if they aren't equal
it will basically show it. So if I apply this will find our basically our requests and responses without
with invalid content length. So that's BAMDAS in a nutshell. The point here is to make your life
easier by offering a quicker way to customize your filter right where you need it. If you have any
thoughts or ideas on this especially where you'd like to see BAMDAS, I need some feedback. Cheers.
Thank you.